c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le dilemme qui se pose
aujourd'hui au gouvernement français est
le suivant le variant britannique duke
au vide et en plus contagieux si on ne
parvient pas à stopper sa circulation en
france il va devenir majoritaire et
comme il se transmet plus vite il risque
d'envoyer plus de monde à l'hôpital et
si les hôpitaux sont débordés
d'entraîner plus de décès donc le
gouvernement peut décider demain de nous
re confiné sans attendre aussi
strictement qu'au mois de mars
considérant que c'est le meilleur moyen
d'enrayer la progression de ce satané
variant éviter la situation de la grande
bretagne mais il peut aussi se dire
attendez on n'est pas comme au mois de
mars on a des tests on peut isoler les
cas positifs empêcher le virus de se
répandre partout et en plus on a un
vaccin
on a même deux vaccins il suffit de
vacciner le plus grand nombre de gens le
plus vite possible et en attendant
d'atteindre l'immunité collective de
réduire les interactions sociales en
avançant par tout le couvre feu de 18h
par exemple ça devrait suffire
c'est l'autre option moins radicale mais
qui al'avantage de ne pas remettre tout
le pays à l'arrêt en fermant les écoles
et les entreprises et en renvoyant tout
le monde à la maison alors que choisir
pour en débattre nous avons invité
christian bréchot vous êtes virologues
professeur à l'université de floride du
floride du sud présidente global virus
network vous avez été directeur général
de l'inserm
de 2000 à 2007 de l'institut mérieux de
2008 à 2013 de l'institut pasteur de
2013 à 2017
imaginez que vous soyez à la place de
jean castex ou des bagnoles macron vous
êtes au gouvernement vous choisiriez
quelle option
je pense que je ne choisirai pas de
refaire dès maintenant un confinement
total et j'essaierai de me donner un
petit peu de temps parce que les
chiffres qui vont apparaître dans les
dix jours vont être importants et en
renforçant certaines mesures mais en
même temps que c'est que vous prenez un
risque on a fait la même chose au moment
où en mars et l italie qu'on regardait à
l'époque on s'est dit on va se laisser
un peu de temps on va pas confiné tout
de suite on va attendre on va attendre
puis quand on a un confiné c'est déjà un
peu tard on prend un très gros risque de
or de toute façon quelle que soit la
solution qui sera trouvée y aura un
risque très fort qui est pris mais comme
vous l'avez dit dans votre introduction
il ya la vaccination et il ya des tests
diagnostiques et évidemment cette
attitude n'est jouable que si un effort
énorme énorme sur la vaccination est pas
petit bras
mais de toute façon c'est une décision
extraordinairement difficile
stéphane caillet vous vous êtes
infectiologues au chu de strasbourg
chargé d'enseignement à l'université de
strasbourg vous êtes le premier vice
président de l'observatoire régional de
la santé d'alsace et de son conseil
scientifique et vous êtes l'auteur et le
responsable du site internet qualité et
sécurité des soins
si vous étiez au gouvernement
aujourd'hui vous choisiriez quelle
option
alors bon soir frédéric taddéï est je
remercie de votre invitation
le le premier confinement a été un grand
succès on le voit en examinant
précisément les courbe épidémiologique
et il a été vraiment efficace en
revanche je pense que le deuxième
confinement a été beaucoup moins
efficace on a eu la conjonction des
effets du premier couvre-feu et du
deuxième confinement mais ce deuxième
confinement et d'après ce que je vois à
la lecture des courbe épidémique est
beaucoup moins efficace que le premier
on notera aussi tout aussi il n'est pas
dit il n'est pas aussi strictes et puis
autant lors du premier confinement il y
a eu une observance stricte vraiment
rigoureuses de la part de la population
à strasbourg lors du premier confinement
et c'était une ville morte
personne dans les rues aucune voiture
vraiment il était très bien observé et
là lors du deuxième confinement on ne
voit pas du tout ça et de fait les
effets ne sont pas là je pense que on a
peut trouver les limites du
confinement et je ne suis pas pour du
tout un troisième confinement je pense
qu'il faudrait essayer de l'utiliser au
maximum le couvre-feu mais ça peut se
discuter
et puis c'est surtout revoir la la
sensibilisation la formation les
instructions des gens concernant le port
du masque parce que il ya bien des
choses à revoir
concernant la désinfection des mains et
les comportements
je pense que nous n'avons pas été assez
éducatif et qu'il faut voir revoir
complètement le programme éducatif de la
population et surtout la
responsabilisation individuelle parce
qu'on a affaire à une maladie qu'est
collective mais je pense que la
prévention doit être plus individuelle
que ce qu'elle n'est jusqu'à présent
philippe ullmann vous vous êtes
philosophe des sciences directeur de
recherche à l'institut d'histoire et de
philosophie des sciences et des
techniques votre dernier livre
s'intitule pourquoi une question pour
découvrir le monde
il est paru aux éditions autrement alors
imaginez que vous êtes à la place de
jean castex houde emmanuel macron vous
feriez quel choix bonjour il bonjour
c'est ça c'est vraiment un chouette
c'est un choix difficile d'écouter
jeunes j'avoue que d'un côté le
confinement c'est quelque chose dont
tout le monde en a assez il est clair
que les locaux de d'épuisement de 2,2
sans doute le coût psychologique
dépression mal être et ses raids de plus
en plus énormes le coût financier aussi
après jeu sans doute il faudrait
attendre quelques jours pour regarder
les courbes et ne rien exclure comme
option
sachant qu effectivement il ya un an le
le le le sud de l'incertitude sur le
degré auquel le variant anglais est
entré en france et on savait qu
effectivement sa transmission est bien
supérieure après moi j'ai pas de pouvoir
décisionnel et j'ai pas de compétence
sur donc je n'ai pas de compétence sur
la politique de santé publique donc je
pense que je dirais quelque chose comme
bâle attendrait une semaine voilà voilà
mais il faut se dire que jean castex n'a
pas de compétence ne former plus de nick
non plus ni manuellement oui mais voilà
il sort bien devoir est de prendre une
décision
voilà oui oui elle ment mais ils sont
entourés quand même ils ont peut-être
plus d'accès aux informations et aux
conseils pertinents que moi qu'ils ont
fait ils ont tellement de conseils
autour de qui on se demande à la fin si
ça ne serait pas tenue qui décide tout
seul
roland gori vous vous êtes professeur
honoraire de psychologie et de
psychopathologie à l'université
d'aix-marseille et vous êtes
psychanalyste votre dernier livre c'est
ici l'effondrement avait déjà eu lieu
l'étrange défaite de nos croyances et le
tout titre c'est paru aux liens qui
libèrent alors vous vous seriez à la
place au gouvernement aujourd'hui vous
prendriez quelle décision c'est un sacré
dilemme un oui bonsoir et merci de
m'avoir invité
je ne me prononcerai pas par un wind
renault
sur cette question je pense si vous
voulez que ce qui doit être recherché
c'est un confinement si elle est
nécessaire qu'ils soient accompagnés
qu'ils soient assistés c'est à dire
qu'ils ne viennent pas pulvérisé la
cohésion sociale dont nous avons besoin
pour lutter contre les épidémies
efficacité de pour prévenir d'abord et
pour lutter contre et c'est justement la
cohésion sociale donc si vous voulez ce
que veut dire par là c'est qu'il
conviendrait donc je demande regarder
les courbes des années 14 dont seulement
d'être de piloter je dirais
attentivement à lui et peut-être manière
très nuancée d'une région d'un
département d'une vie voire d'un quart
c'est à l'autre je crois que nous avons
finalement trop tendance à voir les
choses de manière radicale est totale
pour que l'essentiel
le message que je prie passé c'est que
si nous devions confiné il faudrait le
fait avec l'assentiment des citoyens
c'est à dire les impliqués dans les
décisions
ceux qui n'aiment pas l'idée fait la
démocratie ça suppose justement la
participation des décisions accompagnés
par des rencontres avec les élus locaux
avec si vous voulez des citoyens et bien
évidemment au fur à mesure du bouger des
indicateurs l'état prenne ses
responsabilités mais encore une fois il
s'agit pas de confiner comme on en voit
des enfants dans leur chambre
il s'agit de faire participer les
citoyens il s'agit de s'appuyer sur les
élus locaux et régionaux
il s'agit de s'appuyer aussi sur les
chambres syndicales les corporations je
vais y associer les gens étaient
terribles en asie et qui effectivement a
peut-être produit loin des faits avec le
deuxième compte non seulement il a été
moins strict mais encore une fois il n'a
pas été accompagnée par les citoyens on
y reviendra et le confinement c'est une
privation de liberté la liberté c'est la
capacité de se mouvoir la capacité
d'agir pour y renoncer
cela suppose une décision beaucoup plus
collective nationale qu'elle n'a été
souveraineté nationale et doit de
sanitaires mais de votre si politique
alors là le problème évidemment c'est
qu'on est dans dans une situation où
tout peut changer très vite et est alors
l'âme après l'acte est sûre elle sera
pour nos deux médecins virologues
infectiologues est-ce qu'on peut encore
espérer empêcher le variant britannique
de circuler en france et de devenir
majoritaire est ce qu'on a les moyens
aujourd'hui de
de tester les cas qui ont déjà été
touchés par ce variant de les isoler de
l'etrat c est ce qu on est encore on a
encore cette possibilité je rappelle on
est un peu dans la même situation qu'en
février mars un canton regardez l'italie
on se disait ben nous on va y arriver on
va arriver ralentir l'épidémie à la
contrôler on a vu ce qui est arrivé mais
est ce que aujourd'hui on a quand même
beaucoup évolué et est ce qu'on en
aurait les moyens à votre avis philippe
bruchot e christian bréchot basse pardon
écoutez c'est là encore c'est une
question très difficile je pense qu'il
faut avoir beaucoup d'humilité parce que
ce virus
malheureusement nous a surpris et
beaucoup de choses n'avaient pas été
prédite
moi je pense personnellement que nous
sommes par rapport à aux comparaisons
nous sommes également dans la même
situation que le royaume uni au début du
mois d'octobre si vous regardez les
courbes
c'est à dire qu'on est dans la phase de
début de l'apparition de ce variant
j'espère me tromper mais je dirais que
je ne vois pas très bien comment on peut
empêcher un variant qui est nettement
plus contagieux de prendre le dessus sur
les autres espèces virale et de devenir
l'espèce majoritaire il faut se rappeler
qu'on a eu une première mutation qui est
survenu en février 1 et cette mutation
elle a donné un avantage est faux virus
qui est devenu plus contagieux et c'est
ce virus qui a diffusé dans le monde
entier et qui maintenant représente
d'une certaine manière la souche de
référence
ensuite on a eu des variole qui sont
survenus en particulier au danemark et
en hollande
du fait des transmissions avec le vison
mais ils ont été moins diffusés et puis
arrive effectivement ce variant engrais
qui lui a vraiment si je peux me
permettre de parler comme ça un
équipement qui lui permet vraiment
d'aller vite qui a pris le dessus de
façon très rapide et il est déjà en
france de même entre parenthèses qu'il
est en bien d'autres pays et je vis aux
états unis qu'il est aux états unis on
le voit très bien
donc est-ce qu'on peut ré
le monde l'empêcher on peut ralentir ça
oui mais est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
l'empêcher de prendre le dessus je crois
qu'il faut vraiment prendre le problème
un peu différemment il faut il faut se
mettre dans le scénario le moins bon et
se dire voilà bon si si les contenus à
ses formidables mais le plus probable ce
qui va prendre le dessus dans qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut pas dire que la
maladie est plus grave que s'il ne donne
pas une maladie plus grave
mais ça veut dire ce que vous disiez en
introduction que l'on va avoir beaucoup
plus de cas est ce que c'est plus
contagieux et donc on arrive
effectivement à des situations de
saturation etc
et bien moi je suis désolé de répéter
toujours toujours la même chose mais
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'a dit stéphane
caillet je pense qu'il ya il n'y a pas
36 manières il ya premièrement bien
réfléchir sur que tout ce qui est
précaution le masque de la seule absence
de rassemblement le lavage des mains sur
des choses élémentaires mais
fondamentales pendant une épidémie
et puis vacciner vacciner vacciner alors
stéphane caillet et prenons le scénario
le pire il est déjà là il va devenir le
variant il va devenir majoritaire on n'y
pourra rien pourquoi est ce qu on isole
pas en france c'est ce que vous avez
c'est très cette réponse parce que c'est
ce que le ms nous conseille depuis le
début testez isolé tracé maintenant on
la déteste on peut tester mais on isole
toujours pas pourquoi en france on isole
pas déjà donc je bien sûr je m'associe à
à christian bréchot ce virus ce variant
britannique étant donné qu'il est plus
contagieux qui se transmet plus
facilement
forcément il va arriver en france c'est
inéluctable et il va petit à petit
prendre le pas sur l'autre
c'est souvent ce que l'on voit
d'ailleurs dans dans les épidémies
virales surtout respiratoires c'est
qu'il y a des variants qui apparaissent
et qui sont souvent moins virulent que
les premiers ça semble être le cas il
est plus contagieux c'est à dire que le
fameux air zéro le taux de reproduction
de base
et plus important que la souche original
mais en même temps semble-t-il il
donnerait des formes moins sévère c'est
à dire avec des signes pointent moins
importants - moins graves
alors concernant les possibilités on a
eu énormément de mal à endiguer
l'épidémie depuis le mois de mars et on
a tous été surpris comme l'a rappelé
christian bréchot on a été surpris par
l'intensité de la première vague et
aussi par le pouvoir pathogène
particulier parce que c'est un virus
comme on en a pas connu à part le ca
reçoivent un
mais il a un pouvoir pathogène vraiment
très très singulier qui qui qui nous
déroute et c'est l'occasion de parler
des femmes prolongée il y a des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
ont fait une qu'ovide des personnes
souvent jeunes en très bonne santé jusqu
alors et qui ne guérissent pas qu'ils
sont toujours handicapé dans un état
d'invalidité et très souffrante bout
alors maintenant pour en revenir à votre
question pourquoi n'est elle tente pas
on a beaucoup dit phil difficultés en
france vraiment beaucoup de 10 je crois
qu'il n'est pas exagéré de dire que
depuis le début c'est à dire fin février
début mars
la gestion était quand même assez mal a
assez mal commencé rappelez vous il ya
eu les élections municipales on a
d'abord dit qu'il ne fallait pas les
différer et puis le premier tour des
élections municipales terminé toutes
affaires cessantes
il fallait se dépêcher mardi 17 mars de
commencer le 1er confinement un peu dans
la précipitation donc vraiment ça a très
mal commencé et on n'est pas capable de
d'isoler les gens on n'y arrive pas pour
tout un ensemble de raisons et bien il y
a les français n'ont jamais été
excellente discipline je crois
il faut le dire il faut le rappeler et
puis depuis le début de l'épidémie en
france il ya une perte de confiance ya
une perte de confiance parce qu'il ya eu
trop d'hésitations juste un exemple la
distance de sécurité
le pouvoir exécutif a dit qu'il fallait
observer une distance d'un mètre
en réalité la distance année d'un mètre
cinquante et dans tous les hôpitaux vous
pouvez voir dans les halls d'accueil
dans les cliniques qu'il faut observer
une licence d'un mètre cinquante donc a
eu déjà une maladresse à propos de cette
distance les maladresses sont également
répété du masque on a un peu mélangé les
masques unidirectionnelle comme le
masque chirurgical avec les masses
bidirectionnelle am le masque afnor les
masques ffp2 donc beaucoup de consignes
ont été hésitants tu
de plus la communication n'a pas été
toujours satisfaisantes mais stephen
gayet parle pardon je vous interromps
pour mais d'après ce que vous nous dites
justement vu qu'il ya eu tellement
d'hésitation et qu'on a ratés en france
à peu près toutes les étapes qu'on
voulait pouvait rater est ce que ça ne
plaiderait pas en faveur justement d'art
confinement strict ont pour une fois ne
prenons pas de retard anticipons et si
on ne veut pas se retrouver comme nous
sommes dans la situation dans laquelle
se trouvent les anglais d'ici très peu
de temps
ben on confine ont tout de suite
et puis tant pis on sait bien on va en
parler tous les problèmes que cela pose
mais voilà au moins pour une fois on
n'aura pas hésité on n'aura pas traîné
on aura anticipé franchement je ne suis
pas pour du tout et je vais essayer de
me justifier la courbe épidémique
actuellement elle est stationnaire c'est
à dire que la deuxième vague qui m'a
surpris je vous avoue que je fais partie
de ceux qui en juillet et en août ne
croyait pas à la survenue d'une deuxième
vague
et puis elle est arrivée elle est un peu
moins forte que la première mais elle
s'étale en largeur et actuellement on
est dans une phase stationnaire c'est à
dire qu'il y à peu près chaque jour
environ 1600 nouveaux nouvelles
hospitalisations pour coville 19 et
chaque jour environ 200 nouvelle
admission en réanimation pour coville 19
mai la situation aujourd'hui elle est
allée stationnaire c'est à dire qu'on
est très très loin bien sûr de la
situation très favorable de juillet
d'août mais ça ne nous on ne voit pas
une augmentation du nombre de cas ce qui
est vrai aussi sur les images on est à
trois sont morts par jour et la loi sont
en fait un jour voilà et ça et ça
n'augmente pas mais bon votre panier
hier il ya eu 1200 43 morts et on se dit
que c'est peut-être ce qui nous attend
je voulais passer la parole à roland
gori
vous n'êtes pas idiots biologiste vous
n'êtes pas virologues bien entendu mais
dans ces cas là c'est que c'est quoi la
question qui se pose effectivement
aujourd'hui le dilemme dont je parlais
tout à l'heure vous voyez comment vous
la question qui chauffe eau ces cases
unités les facteurs favorisant
l'émergence de l'épidémie qui n'est pas
un agresseur extérieur et qu'il y aussi
à la manière à nos modes de vie et la
manière dont nous avons altérer notre
biotope
je crois que c'est un point très
important sur lequel nous reviendrons
la question qui se pose c'est qu'est ce
qui a conduit à une telle impréparation
qu'effectivement les pays et des
citoyens ont vécu un traumatisme en
traumatismes chez hm plant
psychopathologique c'est pas l'intensité
du choc
c'est l'état de sidération produit par
un chant quel qu'il soit en fonction de
l'état d'un bonjour quoi si vous voulez
que c'est cela aussi que nous devons
poser comme question je vais sans doute
le vis très mal emportements tout à
l'heure mais il s'agit de mobiliser des
citoyens
il s'agit de ne pas tomber dans un
individualiste de bath où effectivement
la privation que comporte un confinement
ou encore je veux être vécu comme
l'altération d'une liberté individuelle
c'est pas le problème
si nous décidons collectivement
évidemment de respecter non pas la
distance sociale
j'ai réagi tout de suite quand edouard
lipa par les deux distances sociales
il s'agit d'une distance physique qui
nécessite justement l'accroissement de
dans une relation sociale c'est ce qui
est important
vous avez bien vu comment les gens se
sont précipités pour le début dans ma
région ensuite sur les plages dans les
restaurants aujourd'hui par exemple on
vous dit au niveau des écoles on fait
très attention il ya des mesures
sanitaires
je cherche dans mon quartier et je vois
les parents agglutinés devant l'école il
n'y a pas de descente fini qu il n'y a
pas de recommandation sanitaire comme si
finalement le virus n'était en quelque
sorte que nocif à l'intérieur de l'école
n'est pas autour de l'école donc si vous
voulez je crois qu'il y a joué très
brutal janvier désolé mais une très
mauvaise gestion de l'épidémie
et quand je parlais tout à l'heure de la
pluie sur les instances locales dans la
région par exemple il ya quelque chose
assez extraordinaire je le sais aussi
par les élus locaux
dans ma région si vous voulez les élus
locaux sont prêts à mettre la main à la
pâte sur ont déjà convoqué si vous
voulez des pompiers etc
en gros il y aurait la possibilité
régionalement d'avoir un hack
oui pour pouvoir justement vacciner
parce que c'est ça la solution si si
nous devons faire un confinement
c'est pour en faire quelque chose c'est
pas simplement pour faire une pause en
restant à faire quand fermés dans sa
chambre c'est pour en profiter pour
effectivement vaccinés vacciner maxime
et encore or dans ma région c'est là
c'est une des régions où le virus
circule le plus est la population n'a
pas des vaccins
il ya 0 13% de personnes vaccinées donc
dans la région paca c'est quand même
tout à fait dramatique
alors si vous voulez pour moi la
question de la liberté
la question de la sécurité vont ensemble
et nous sommes dans une véritable course
de vitesse que les uns facture '
connaissent bien parler beaucoup mieux
que moi qui s'appelle la l'hypothèse de
la reine rouge ou en gros le virus se
transforme en même temps que nous nous
transformons en prenant des mesures et
il faut accélérer
or je trouve que nous n'acceptons pas
donc pour moi le problème c'est pas
tellement le gouvernement que la
prévention comment faire face à
l'épidémie
et comment une fois qu'elle est là nous
pouvons prendre des mesures qui soient
ajustés justement aux défis qu'il nous
lance les mesures elles doivent être
prises à tous les niveaux au niveau d'un
millefeuille qui va depuis le quartier
depuis l'immeuble jusqu'à à je dirais
les instances internationales parce que
la mondialisation a participé bien
évidemment une plus grande circulation
des micros et ça n'est pas terminé mais
il fallait aussi se doter d'un
dispositif sanitaire et social à la
hauteur de l'inde mondialisation
financière et économique
on va faire une pause on se retrouve
juste après je donnerai la parole à
philippe ullmann
[Musique]
le royaume uni la thielle sortir gagnant
du break site
nous allons rester voisins et amis de
l'union européenne mais faisons partie
de l'europe
rien ne va changer cela maintenant
qu'ils sont sortis c'est là que les
choses vont commencer c'est pas un point
final du tout les choses commencent au
contraire plutôt que de finir année aux
clés il est clair que bien qu lieu soit
un partenaire très puissant mieux
exporté bien plus vers le royaume uni
comme vous l'avez dit que le royaume uni
vers lui il faut bien comprendre que
c'est sur la circulation des biens et
sur la production bien si nous qui
sommes perdants c'est les européens
ce qu'on attend un peu de vous c'est les
idées pour en sortir est votre jugement
notamment de la façon dont cette crise
est gérée ce qui a été montré au cours
de la gestion de cette crise c'est le
déficit d'anticipation pour moi la
politique c'est d'abord d'être efficace
dès qu'un manque de cohérence
il ya il ya un manque de fiabilité il ya
un manque de confiance faut vite
retrouver la confiance vous considérer
aujourd'hui que que la france a été plus
mauvaise que beaucoup de nos payes et
étrangers pour le pays qui a inventé les
vaccins avec pasteur dont la réactivité
française n'a pas été à la hauteur de
notre réputation tout le monde a vu que
dès le mois de juillet les chinois
vacciner pourquoi est-ce qu'on a attendu
si longtemps
la question est de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va retrouver un équilibre en
faisant en sorte que les épreuves que
nous subissons actuellement deviennent
des forces et non pas des handicaps
durable
[Musique]
la grande bretagne a eu 1243 mort hier
quatre fois plus que qu'ici en france
et pour cause pitot saturer le variant
britannique qui se transmet plus vite
c'est peut-être ces mêmes sans doute ce
qui nous attend d'ici peu on continue ce
débat sur le dilemme qu'occupe
aujourd'hui le gouvernement française
débat avec christian bréchot qui est
virologues avec stéphane gay qui est
infectiologues avec philippe une manne
qui est philosophe des sciences et avec
roland gori qui est professeur de
psychologie de psychopathologie et
psychanalyste alors que philippe ullmann
ce dilemme
philosophiquement il est intéressant en
gros on se dit soit de maj annoncent
leur confinement total est comme ça je
pourrais dire j'ai sauvé du monde ou
alors se dire bah tant pis
il y aura certainement plus de morts
mais mais après tour confiner ces crée
de la pauvreté c'est créer de l'anxiété
s'est créé du malheur et ça aussi ça
donne des bords voilà dilemme
philosophiquement intéressant non oui
alors ça après ça a été c'est ce qui a
été dit un petit peu depuis le début
c'est à dire que il ya une tension entre
ce qu'on décide et qui effectivement est
vite des morts que ce soit des décès dus
aux corridas et aussi et se met aussi et
surtout des décès dus à la saturation
totale des hôpitaux et où on confine
plus ou moins durement et effectivement
on a un coup à plus long terme parce que
on sait très bien que si l'économie
marche pas les gens sont pas payer les
gens sont les les gens sont enfermés
comme ça chez eux sans pouvoir sortir
leur bien-être et leur équilibre
psychologique et financier va s'écrouler
et s'écroule et évidemment de manière
beaucoup plus net c'est les gens qui
sont dans les classes les moins
favorisées donc ça on l'a vu après c'est
pas la totalité de la situation
puisqu'il ya bien entendu il ya la
question de la vaccination qui est très
importante et comme comme ça veut dire
d'être appelé il ya une course entre la
proportion de la population qui va être
vaccinés et la vitesse à laquelle le
virus et ces variants en particulier les
variants les plus les plus contagieux se
répandent dans la population
moi ce que je voulais dire c'est aussi
que je pense qu'il ya plusieurs aspects
et c'est pour ça que je dis que yahia la
vaccination il ya le la manière dont le
les hôpitaux sont à la manière dont les
hôpitaux ont été moins été gérée et à
lormont donc j'ai pas de gêne à dire que
le corps d'un virus a été très très mal
gérée comme à elle a été rappelée par
roland gori suis tout à fait d'accord et
je pense que ça a été géré très mal
depuis très longtemps c'est là qu'on
paie aussi le prix et ça a été dit de du
de certains disent la casse systématique
des hôpitaux et la santé publique mais
c'est certain que s'il y avait eu plus
de lits et on supprime encore des lits
en ce moment là est le problème de la
saturation des hôpitaux seraient sans
doute
beaucoup moins nette le don de manière
un peu plus générale pas parler de ce
qui est philosophiquement intéressant je
pense que et j'abonde est vraiment dans
le sens de ce que dit gorom roland gori
ce qu'on voit c'est cdc l'effet de ce
qui a été nommé le néolibéralisme depuis
une trentaine d'années terre une
politique quand même d'exacerbation de
la concurrence entre les instances et
les individus d'une part d'autre part de
de maximisation de la spéculation des
flux que soient économiques marchandises
tout ce que vous voulez et donc de et
donc le réduction de ski jane les flux
c'est à dire les stocks il ya une file
au philosophe barbara stiegler qui vient
d'écrire et et qui écrit depuis quelques
temps là dessus et qu'il s'est saisi du
corps en un virus pour le dire mais
c'est très juste par exemple si vous
prenez la prévision on avait un plan
pandémie on avait des masques on les a
brûlés parce qu'on veut avant juste
avant de covin pas pourquoi parce qu'on
veut pas de stock
et qu'est ce que c'est quoi l'envers de
ce buzz cette double accent sur d'une
part la compétition interindividuelle et
d'autre part la circulation des flux
contre les stocks
c'est ce qui s'appelle le solutionner
technologique stern c'est l'idée que ben
si on a un problème de toute façon leur
à une conclusion logique alors là on a
deux vaccins heureusement et faire ça a
été soulignée et une grande prouesse de
la science si rapidement un vaccin
néanmoins il est quelque chose de très
symptomatique dans l'idée qu'on supprime
le plan pandémie il ya une pandémie à
laquelle en gros la plupart des
écologues sur laquelle la plupart des
écologues avait attiré l'attention parce
qu'on savait très bien que ce genre de
problème dans le type d'économie
mondialisée avec l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles destruction des
interfaces entre faune sauvage et et
urbanisme etc
et elles valent intensifs on s'attend à
des choses comme ça donc mais on ne
prévoit rien on se dit qu'on aura une
solution technologique on l'a donc
situer ce qu'on voit là c'est le double
le solutionner technologique est une
autre chose qui moi même
me gêne terriblement depuis le début
c'est un accent sur la responsabilité
individuelle et on voit exactement la
même chose que dans le réchauffement
climatique a des gens qui arrêtent pas
être vous dira si vous triez vos déchets
si vous triez votre verre on va rentrer
de réchauffement climatique bah non
c'est pas ça est oxydé tout un tas
d'industrie était pas allé de deux
d'entreprise de deux très grosses en
général et c'est qui est donc tout un
système économique qui produit le
réchauffement climatique ici c'est
pareil on fait tout un tout un foin de
2000 rêveur est reparti en bretagne qui
sont complètement irresponsable ok mais
il est clair aussi que on a des écoles
moi j'avais des universités j'ai des
collègues qui jusqu'en novembre enseigné
à 60 dans des salles sans fenêtre et ben
c'est c'est des millions de gens qui
sont exposés et pas par le fait que
c'est des fêtards et qui vont faire la
fête par l'état français et la politique
en termes de l'éducation nationale est
là le voit le note ministre la ministre
de la recherche disait oui c'est
embêtant parce que les étudiants ils
sont il laisse traîner des bonbons ils
mangent des bonbons il laisse traîner
les bonbons et comme ça il s'injecte bon
alors hormis le fait que ça sort
complètement de groland enfin c'est ces
extrêmes vous dire une chose pareille
c'est extra c'est un écossais un degré
de mépris complètement dingue pour les
pour les étudiants ça ça signale aussi
le fait on veut pas s'avouer que la
responsabilité elle est allée des
instants c'est elle et elle est d'un
certain nombre de choix de deux indices
us d'institutions politiques ou privés
qui entretiennent ça et donc si on a
d'un côté d un ministre il dit c'est la
faute des étudiants et d'un autre côté
un autre ministre qui dit mais il ya pas
de problème d'aération parce qu'en fait
c'est pas l'aération qui entretient le
le la contagion dont va pas acheter des
ventilateurs on va pas faire toute une
politique très serré de ventilation dans
nos universités
mais bon ce qu'on se retrouve avec avec
ce conte à la bleue et et est alors
qu'en fait par ailleurs l'une des rares
choses qu'on a appris sur le coronavirus
enfin se corrigera si je me trompe c'est
que l'un des gros vecteur de contagion
c'est pas les gens qui par exemple se
déballe les paquets les pas des balles
des packs avec les mains et se sont pas
levés laver les mains de 100 fois par
jour auxquels bien sûr il faut se laver
les mains
mais c'est l'air l'air qu'on respire en
l'espèce fermés et ça on le sait on le
sait depuis août à peu près août ou
septembre
qu'est ce qui a été fait là dessus en
terme de politique pas grand chose en
fait donc donc on dénonce les coupables
les méchants qui ne respectent pas les
gestes barrières les gens qui vont se
ruer dans les dents les terrasses dans
les îles vont faire des fêtes à 8 au
lieu de six et d'un autre côté avoir une
politique responsable
appuyez sur ce que la science a pris
mieux depuis que le sar skov de et
didier existe pas en france on a pas
voilà donc c'est bien facile de
critiquer le g aucune décision à prendre
aucune responsabilité
ceci dit je pense qu'il faut quand même
que les questions brèche s'il ya une
chose dont on est sûr c'est que sur le
plan sanitaire
aujourd'hui si on veut combattre le plus
efficacement possible
la contagion liés à ce nouveau variant
britannique
il faut confiné strictement sur le plan
sanitaire on sait que c'est la meilleure
solution mais on sait aussi qu'elle
qu'elle a sa contingence de deux
problèmes socio économiques voilà et au
fond on sait autant de bonnes raisons
pour ne pas appliquer la meilleure
solution sanitaires
on peut les comprendre au gouvernement
ils peuvent se dire il vaut mieux qu'ils
aient un peu plus de morts tout de suite
que beaucoup plus de dégâts sociaux
économiques et et un manteau d'ici
quelques semaines ou quelques mois
oui mais on peut vous avez bien sûr
raison mais on peut également dire parce
que enfin mois par rapport à la vie que
j'ai exprimée au tout début quand vous
m'avez questionner moi je pense
personnellement que la différence faut
toujours le rappeler suis désolé le rap
est sur la même chose mais la différence
avec tap le premier confinement sait
qu'on a un vaccin et on sait également
comment d'abord un on a un vaccin et 2
il faut toujours rappeler quand même on
traite on peut pas parler de tout
aujourd'hui mais il faut voir des
progrès thérapeutiques et il ya une au
mieux le traitement soignants aux états
unis sont en train d'arriver et on
traite déjà mieux et stéphane caillet
connais ça très bien mais on a également
par exemple au global voice network et
des traitements qui sont en train
d'arriver pour les formes graves qui
peuvent également changer mais ceci dit
par rapport à votre poids moi je pense
que personnellement je ne donne pas la
vie de ne par confiner complètement en
me disant tant pis pour les morts qui
aura j'ai l'impression peut-être à tort
mais j'ai l'impression que si on avait
une politique vraiment combinant bien
sûr quand même à des mesures de
restriction a donc on parle pas du tout
de liberté ahmed de mesures de
restriction forte mais pas un
confinement total avec vraiment les
mesures de précaution et une vaccination
de masse
moi je pense personnellement peut-être à
tort et je pense que les cours qu a
rappelé stéphane caillet vont dans ce
sens je pense personnellement qu'on peut
éviter encore une une vague massive y
compris dans les hôpitaux mais je
voudrais dire une chose qui est vraiment
parce que sur la vaccination c'est très
bien dire il faut vacciner en masse mais
on sait très bien les difficultés et
philippe ullmann rappelait la situation
dans sa région
stéphane gagné a dit une chose qui est
fondamentale et qui n'est pas assez dit
moi ça me choque profondément quand des
gens qui s'opposent aux vaccins vous
disent c'est pas la peine de vacciner
parce que c'est une maladie qui donne
une mortalité qui est ou qui est très
faible
c'est un scandale de dire ça parce qu on
oublie toutes les personnes dont on a
parlé qui ont des séquelles extrêmement
importante et qu'on commence juste à
découvrir et le co vide 19 il faut le
dire et de redire est une saleté je suis
désolé de parler comme ça mais c'est une
réalité qui induit chez des gens qui ont
eu des formes symptomatiques des
séquelles des séquelles longue des
séquelles invalidantes des séquelles qui
impacte d'économie et c'est la raison
pour laquelle quand on parle de vaccins
on le voit vacciner pas seulement pour
prévenir la mortalité mais pour prévenir
ceux ci et puis l'autre chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que on se fait
prendre sur le diagnostic le diagnostic
passent toujours après c'est à dire
qu'on vous dit c'est très important bien
sûr mais finalement on utilise encore
presque un an après des technologies et
des types de prélèvements qui sont
complètement d'arrière-garde
au global va rester at work on a vu
depuis début de l'été que les
prélèvement salivaire par exemple qui
peuvent permettre de tester de façon
fréquente et ça c'est très important et
qui peuvent permettre justement mieux
par rapport à votre point d'ailleurs
d'isoler et de circonscrire des
techniques rapides moléculaire qui
peuvent remplacer les pcr les tests
rapides on nous a dit cet été que ça
marchait pas et puis après il a bien
fallu admettre que ça marchait dans ce
que je cherche à dire c'est que notre
problème c'est qu'en fait on aurait les
moyens d'éviter un confinement total qui
serait à mon avis dramatiques pour la
population et qu'on peut pas s'offrir
si on combine vraiment l'ensemble des
choses y compris les approches qui ont
été rappelés par roland gori et philippe
ullmann sur l'aspect sociologique et
psychologique de ça et voilà donc
personnellement je termine en disant
pour moi le choix n'est pas tellement
laisser mourir des gens
parce qu'il y en aurait plus après mais
plutôt la conviction mais on est mais il
faut s'en donner les moyens
les israéliens nous ont montré ce que
c'était une vraie vaccination de masse
ils ont montré comment on pouvait très
vite mais alors vraiment il faut se dire
mais là on y va c'est comme ça que ça
marche en fait mais je crois que en
france au mois d'octobre on a vacciné 8
millions de personnes contre la grippe
en très peu de temps donc on sait qu'on
est capables de vacciner beaucoup de
gens ça fait suffisamment longtemps
qu'on vaccine des gens en france si on
ne l'a pas fait là c'est qu'on n'a pas
voulu c'est qu'on a fait un autre choix
de ne pas brusquer les populations de ne
pas de ne pas heurter les antilles ivax
comme on les appelle de même si j'ai
bien compris votre raisonnement
christian bréchot vous dites au fond il
faut tester mais tester efficacement il
faut peut être isolé si on testait
efficacement et puis il faut vacciner
vacciner vacciner la question c'est
est-ce que la france en l'état actuel
est capable de faire tout ça et si elle
n'en est pas capable
quelle conclusion doit-elle en tirer et
c'est en ce moment dans la tête de nos
gouvernants il disait ce que je suis
capable de faire ce que christian
bréchot me dit faire ce que l'om est ce
nous dit faire depuis un an en fait un
est-ce que j'en suis capable et si je
n'en suis pas capable que dois-je faire
est-ce que je dois continuer strictement
les gens ou est-ce que je laisse et je
me dis alors tout on n'est plus capable
de supporter encore une fois un autre
confinement et d'autres mesures
coercitives
alors je pense que effectivement vous
posiez la question mais je pense que
si vous voulez d'abord vous avez raison
de dire qu'on est capable de vacciner
massivement en france mais parfaitement
raison alors c'est vrai que les raisons
pour laquelle on a pris du retard on
déconne et bien c'est exactement ce que
vous avez dit on a beaucoup trop écouté
un certain nombre de personne d'ailleurs
y compris des scientifiques et des
médecins qui à mon avis une grosse
responsabilité dans le retard et
deuxièmement il faut quand même
reconnaître que le vaccin fighter by one
tech c'est pas de vaccin contre la
grippe non long terme puisque
l'administration etc et est donc il faut
quand même temps mais moi je pense
personnellement qu'on a la capacité
je pense qu'on a la capacité
mais effectivement c'est un changement
de paradigme c'est à dire que c'est pas
et ça que der correspond un peu à mon
avis à ce qui a été dit par roland gori
je crois un moment c'est à dire et où
philippe ullmann c'est-à-dire de de dire
il faut que ce soit quelque chose ou une
population décide que on en a assez
qu'on a un problème à résoudre qu'on va
se donner des moyens sur trois quatre
mois de le résoudre et où c'est pas
effectivement un gouvernement
ah j'allais dire contre une population
voyez ce que je veux dire aimer et moi
c'est ce que j'ai admiré dans ce camp
c'est israël est d'ailleurs d'une
certaine manière dans ce que font les
engrais et d'une certaine manière aussi
d'ailleurs
même si ce critique entre ce que font
les américains c'est à dire un moment où
des populations disent écoutez nous on y
va et je pense vraiment et alors on peut
me dire je suis complètement naïf
utopique et ses jets d'habitude et donc
peut-être que mes mais je ne crois pas
et puis alors pour le diagnostic c'est
autre chose on n'a pas la possibilité de
faire ce que je dis actuellement d'une
façon moderne parce qu'on sait pas
donner cette possibilité qu'il aurait
fallu plusieurs mois qu'on savait déjà à
partir du mois de mars avril
ce qu'on pouvait faire là dessus c'est
pas seulement la france dont il faut
être clair c'est beaucoup d'autres pays
et parce que le diagnostic a fait partie
des ratés mais là je suis d'accord on
peut pas là en trois semaines se mettre
en ordre de marche sur le diagnostic de
façon il faut le faire pour la suite
voilà téva de gagner sachant que
effectivement
le temps là nous est compté les
décisions à prendre doivent l'être
rapidement et qu'il s'agit pas de
revenir sur le néolibéralisme où le
patriarcat 1
donc là il va falloir prendre des
décisions en sachant que qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire aujourd'hui éventuellement en
dépit de ce qu'on n'a pas fait hier
bon le pompage de confinement vraiment
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas une solution
satisfaisante
il faut quand même rappeler que la
méthode de confinement vient de
l'élevage
c'est une méthode de médecine
vétérinaire et autant dans les cheptels
c'est une méthode qui marche
là je pense je répète ce que j'ai dit on
a été un peu à la limite de l'efficacité
du confinement ça ne règle rien le
confinement
on supprime la circulation des gens il
sert des conséquences dramatiques
et puis quand on arrête et bien tout a
tendance à repartir voilà ce qui s'est
passé en juin juillet et août
le virus a largement circulé on s'est
dit c'est terminé et on l'a vu donc
cette deuxième vague qui nous a surpris
par sa force
non il faut vraiment trouver des
alternatives au confinement qui à mon
avis a plus d'inconvénients que
davantage je les dis aujourd'hui on voit
des gens portaient le masque dans la rue
partout mais quelle est l'efficacité de
ce masque il y a des gens qui ont des
masques chirurgicaux qui sont des
masques unidirectionnelle qui sont
chiffonné qu'il réutilise à longueur de
journée ils sont portés sous le nez
parfois sous le menton et on ne se pose
pas la question de l'efficacité des
masques jeu il s'agit pas de
culpabiliser les gens ça je suis tout à
fait d'accord sur le fait que c'est
quelque chose il faut éviter mais on
peut les responsabiliser et je les dis
je le répète il faut revoir notre
information notre éducation
il faut mieux expliquer comment circule
le virus
les modes de transmission du virus on en
a un peu parlé tout à l'heure
coronavirus ce n'est pas un virus
respiratoires banal
il a un petit côté entérique c'est à
dire qu'on le retrouve dans les matières
fécales et on n'a pas encore parlé
depuis le début de cette émission de
l'étude épidémiologique de l'utile de
l'utilisation d'un indicateur
épidémiologique qui est la recherche de
la rn virale dans les eaux usées ça a
été fait à new york on a pu voir qu'il y
avait des quartiers où le virus circule
est beaucoup plus que dans d'autres
quartiers
c'est quelque chose qu'on devrait
beaucoup plus utilisés ont utilisé les
mêmes en france où louis ont le tennis
mais pas de façon de façon aussi intense
que faire est actuellement notre
politique c'est surtout les tests rt pcr
et qui sont faits avec je pense
insuffisamment de cohérence à n'est pas
je ne savais pas bien plat mieux
planifier les les gens qui ont un test
sont pour certains ceux qui vont aller
voyager pour d'autres ce qui ont eu un
contact pour d'autres c'est simplement
ce qu'ils sont anxieux qui veulent se
tester donc les tests dont on nous
assène quotidiennement les résultats la
positivité
c'était ce ne sont pas une données
épidémiologiques satisfaisant ce que
vous êtes en train de nous dire stéphane
caillet c'est que le confinement souple
ça ne marche pas que les masques on ne
sait pas les utiliser que que les tests
sont faits en dépit du bon sens en gros
on n'est pas capable de tester
efficacement en france toutes choses que
vous n'êtes pas le seul à le dire
d'ailleurs
non mais ça va la vie elle est
simplement face aux warriors britannique
et à la situation des anglais il nous
reste donc qu'à vacciner le problème
c'est que les anglais où il ya
aujourd'hui quatre fois plus de morts
chaque jour que chez nous il ya aussi 20
fois plus de gens vaccinés que chez nous
donc il risque sur la longueur
effectivement de résoudre le problème
beaucoup plus vite que nous roland gori
je voulais vous
la parole il nous reste sept minutes
alors roland gori et et philippe ullmann
roland gori d'abord très rapidement bien
sûr même si votre émission avec ses
ventes on va pas pouvoir tout régler
or une heure donnée ça se déplie à
plusieurs niveaux bon il ya un premier
niveau par exemple qui a été qui vient
d'être évoqué par stéphane caillet à
savoir l'utilisation des indicateurs des
taux de darren qu'on trouve dans les
eaux usées à marseille orlov et les élus
locaux ont pris l'initiative de
mobiliser les sapeurs pompiers pour
effectivement essayé de déterminer à
quel endroit on trouve justement un
succès at indiqué que le duel de corée
navy et c'est important parce que
pourquoi reconfirmer une ligne on peut
on peut tout aussi et c'est le deuxième
point qui a été évoqué par christian
bréchot tout à l'heure en bourse il
tirer des enseignements des autres pays
c'est à dire les enseignements de la
chine que la parabole du sud est d'une
manière générale d'israël etc
donc si vous voulez c'est pas qu'un
problème franco français c'est d'une
pandémie
donc avec un taureau mais il faut
essayer de voir là où ça marche et là où
ça marche pas et ensuite c'est pas qu'un
problème je crois philosophico politique
je me suis pas fait des graisses
qualifie elle-même de faveur parce que
si vous voulez l'histoire du
néolibéralisme c'est pas quelque chose
qui se baladent en l'air c'est pas
simplement un problème de religion c'est
pas ça elle ne voulait me néolibéralisme
c'est que quand résonne à court terme
on a une rationalité qui est purement
financière à court terme et on a en
effet finalement qu'assez des hôpitaux
et vous reporter à l'ouvragé de frédéric
pierru sur la casse du siècle
donc si vous voulez l'état dans lequel
aujourd'hui je trouve c'est un héritage
de la même manière il va il va de soi
que on n'a quasiment pas parlé ce choix
et sa femme mais ça m'étonne c'est vrai
que c'est un des thèmes de mon livre que
vous avez bien voulu citer ces ou n'at
on pas parler de l'histoire est une
histoire d épidémie en 1832 à new york
1949 simone 1720 à marseille et une
histoire des épidémies et déjà des
débats sur la quarantaine
même si c'est différent
finalement il ya si vous voulez
historiquement des éléments dont nous
pourrions tirer profit et moi je suis
pour et je pense que tous vos invités se
cherche pas d'accord avec moi je suis
pour qu'il y ait une connexion des
recherches en sciences médicales et puis
aussi en sciences sociales
lorsque vous voyez n'est ce pas explosé
mais une épidémie de dengue en 2009 en
floride c'est lié aussi à la crise de
2008 où les gens sont obligés de vendre
leur villa des piscines sont laissés à
l'abandon les moustiques à ce moment-là
prolifèrent et en quelles que soient vos
rêves à dire que la dengue est
l'héritage de la crise financière et
pourtant et pourtant il ya aussi une
connexion entre la microbiologie si vous
voulez de la dengue la crise financière
de 2008 les penman romaine de son je
vais prolonger ce lundi roland gore
roland gori je crois qu'on est assez
d'accord si on prend la question de la
vaccination on est tous d'accord sur le
fait que basse il faut vacciner le plus
de gens possible le plus vite possible
il ya deux choses assez frappante en
france la première c'est le fait que
curieusement toute la politique de
vaccination semblent avoir été indexant
sur ce qu'on appelle les antilles vagues
sous les complotistes
il ya toute personne c'est exactement ce
que ça veut dire complotistes mais il ya
un énorme bruit sur qui et qui est fait
il faut pas leur faire peur il faut pas
il faut il faut pas effrayer les gens
parce qu'on est en france on est les
pires anti vague du monde
héééé au final on pourrait se dire que
ben on a des lacs à vacciner les gens
qui sont pas anti vaccin fait largement
assez de monde et ça suffirait quand
même à progresser contre l'épidémie la
seconde chose c'est que ce court ce
qu'on a vu avec les vaccins c'est par
exemple des questions de wes qu'on va
vacciner et moi très naïvement je me dis
mais quand même on sait qu'il va y avoir
un vaccin on aurait pu réfléchir il ya
six mois
ah ouais ce qu'on va vacciner les gens
et on al impression est vraiment je suis
absolument d'accord avec roland gori que
où on est dans la lah l'impréparation
même la myopie la plus totale regarde ce
qui se passe maintenant et moi je me
rappellerai juste une seconde fille
n'est pas uniquement on a on s'est posé
cette question on a fait le choix en
france de vacciner dans les ehpad
d'abord
et surtout de ne pas faire de
vaccinodromes par exemple parce qu'on
avait peur qu'ils soient vides que les
gens ne veulent pas venir que ça les
effraie c'est un choix on l'a décidé
voilà après oui on a décidé mais on ya
réfléchi on a on a on n'a pas enfin il
semble d'après les échos que j'ai du
personnel médical est ce que ce que je
lis enfin on s'appuie à peine sur les
médecins sur les beaucoup de gens qui
pourraient vacciner qui vaccinent pas on
a l'impression et le fait est que le
plan a été revue à la ddt la dernière
mission tout tout ça c'est de c'est
encore une fois c'est comme quand jean
castex dit en septembre à widnes on
n'est vraiment pas préparé on l'a pas vu
venir et et même le pire la république
en mars alors que alors que toutes les
courbes sont alors on sait depuis
longtemps qui aura la première vague
on le sait depuis très longtemps et non
on est dans ce que les économistes
appellent peut-être la préférence pour
le présent et on voit pas la suite ceci
étant ce qu on arrive à très bien faire
c'est faire très très vite alors là ce
qu'on était en train de faire depuis
longtemps terre la digitalisation de la
société vous avez plein de gens qui
viennent vous vendre l'action zoom qui
explose enfin sans faire mon gauchistes
même si mes 2 me soit un peu mais mais
on est dans l'accélération dans des
tendances de fond en particulier dans
encore une fois un la laine la
digitalisation la désocialisation la
laddh la socialisation à distance la
numérisation de tous et ça on le fait
très vite parce qu'au fond on était en
train de le faire depuis dix ans et on
va le faire de plus en plus vite
mais en revanche se préparer et écouter
les gens qui parlaient de l'avenir
depuis encore une fois dix ans et qui
parlait des épidémies et ou non à l'or
bat le plan vaccination de semble
totalement déficient
mais c'est parce que c'est l'idée même
de plans en fait qui donne l'idée même
de se préparer à l'avenir et de ne
planifiez un peu qui semble avoir été
quasiment jetés à la poubelle avec
l'union soviétique coincée et il est je
pense qu'on paye un peu ça voilà je veux
pas être trop long donc moi je m'arrête
là mais cette vaccination qui semble
être encore une fois sans plan sans
préparation on va on va on va nous dire
du lundi au mercredi dans trois mois
qu'on est dans la quatrième vague et
qu'on n'avait pas pu venir mais alors là
la quatrième fois qu'on nous fait le
coup c'est quand même assez
assez navrant quoi je vous remercie tous
les quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
en tout cas en ce qui concerne le
gouvernement on sait qu'on connaîtra sa
réponse au dilemme demain
on peut déjà faire des paris et je vous
remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat je veux remercier
de l'avoir suivi et je vous donne
rendez-vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]